the Democrat Governor of North Carolina
has declared a state of emergency
no there wasn't any natural disaster no
terrorists have not set off a dirty bomb
no no for Democrats
something far worse occurred
Republican legislators
are offering to let North Carolinians
choose where to send their kids to
school
I'm declaring this state of emergency
because you need to know what's
happening
if you care about public schools in
North Carolina
it's time to take immediate action and
tell them to stop the damage that will
set back our schools for a generation
here's what's happening in the next few
weeks
their private school voucher scheme will
pour your tax money into private schools
oh no here's what's going to happen in
the next few weeks their scheme is going
to let you send your kid to good schools
instead of the bad schools that you're
currently forced to send your kids to
the horror
still though
that state of emergency declaration
seems a little bit odd since nearly
seventy seven zero percent of North
Carolinians support school choice
also a little bit odd since the bill has
been passed by the people's duly elected
representatives who ran for office on
school choice but the oddest part of the
Declaration
is that Governor Cooper
sends his own kids
to private school you know those awful
evil terrible unaccountable private
schools that you should definitely not
send your kids to he sends his kids to
them that's kind of weird
but this is an emergency to the Democrat
political agenda for liberals control
over the schools constitutes the
foundation of their power it's the
furthest reaching power base they've got
it's a generational power base
they know that if students have a choice
to receive a decent education the kind
of education that Governor Cooper's
children for instance are able to
receive then they'll be less likely to
fall for the deceits of the power mad
politicians who want to keep all the
Privileges for themselves I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
we need a state of emergency pretty soon
if we don't stop this your kids might be
allowed to go to school with my kids we
can't have that
my fancy kids got to go to the school
that none of you are at below I go to oh
okay all right governor keep up that
state of emergency that's not even the
craziest story of the day we do have
coming up
a long time left-wing therapist who made
an important observation about wokeness
and the secular salvation for white
people's Souls
we'll get to that
eccentric idea in just a little bit
first though
huge fight
over
Sports
and I guess education and I guess the
whole way our society views itself this
out of my old home Gamora by the Sea Los
Angeles I was just back there to do some
shoots for my prageru book club show and
before I left for California there was a
big hubbub because there's a pro drag
group
that is very anti-christian specifically
anti-catholic but broadly very
sacrilegious it's called The Sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence and this group
exists to mock Christianity mock
religious orders mock our Lord and mock
virtue and and pervert all of it into
sin and make fun of of religious people
okay so they were going to be honored at
Dodger Stadium as part of pride month
festivities in the middle of June and
there was naturally an outcry over this
this was extremely offensive and so then
the LA Dodgers said okay we're not going
to invite this degenerate group to to
the middle of the stadium to honor them
in the middle of June and then there was
an outcry from the pro-lgbt group and so
the Dodgers have come back and they said
okay we're reinviting the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence after much
thoughtful feedback from our diverse
communities honest conversations within
the LA Dodgers organization and generous
discussions with the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence the LA Dodgers
would like to offer a sincerest
apologize to the apologies to the
sisters members of the lgbtq plus
community and their friends and Families
we've asked the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence to take their place on the
field of our 10th Annual lgbtq Pride
night on June 16th we're pleased to
share that they've agreed to receive the
Gratitude of our Collective communities
wait for this for the life-saving work
that they have done tirelessly for
decades
life-saving work so jiggling around for
drunk drug addled weirdos that's
life-saving work mocking Christianity
and engaging in extremely perverse
burlesque and Cabaret acts that is
life-saving work meanwhile you've got
actual Catholic nuns who are literally
saving people's lives taking care of
little babies taking care of the elderly
taking care of the sick they're never
going to get their night at Dodgers
Stadium not going to happen but the the
weird sex Troop that mocks those nuns
they get honored for their life-saving
work
and then you got the Dodgers logo there
in the in the rainbow flag the rainbow
flag which is as far as I'm concerned is
the the most dangerous hate symbol in
the country hear about all these hate
symbols you know there's this is these
are very offensive symbols we've got to
run away from the hate symbols to me
nothing tells me that you are on the
wrong side of things quite like that
pride flag The Pride Flag represents
pride is the deadliest of the seven
deadly sins and now these Maniacs are
are honoring a group of
anti-catholic anti-religious perverts
now what's the takeaway from this well I
guess the takeaway is that the LA
Dodgers have become Elga Dodgers am I
right but but if if I had to find any
deeper meaning in all of this the
meaning is this
the Dodgers have to pick between actual
religious sisters and
the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
these dudes jailing around making fun of
Christ they have to choose one of those
things
because if they invite this drag troop
they're going to offend the Christians
if they disinvite the drag troop they're
going to offend the sexual
revolutionaries and the libs
they have to pick one and the Dodgers
said okay we're going to offend the
Christians who cares about the
Christians we don't like the Christians
we're so we're going to side with the
sexual revolutionaries and all the libs
in the short term they probably made the
right choice because that is where the
powerful people in our culture are
that's the camp that they reside in
so they say okay we're going to pick the
politically correct one we're going to
pick the side of ESG we're going to pick
the side of the liberal establishment
we're going to pick the side of of the
media and the colleges and all the rest
of it in the long run I think they
picked the wrong side in the let's say
Eternal run I think they definitely
picked the wrong side here
but they do have to pick a side and the
squishes who want to say well we'll just
be neutral about all this you can't be
neutral either the sacrilegious drag
queens get invited to the baseball
stadium the public place the this
Central public place built in part with
taxpayer money for the sports and the
games which always have a patriotic
public role in any society either the
drag queens get invited to the center of
the field or they don't
either the Christians get to set the
Norms or the weirdos get to set the
Norms there are lots of different kinds
of weirdos but in particular the lib
sexual revolutionary weirdos but
someone's going to set them
somebody is going to set them I would
rather it be the people who are in favor
of the good the true and the Beautiful
but that's not the way the culture is
looking right now
you want to simplify your culture you
want to simplify your business finances
well you got to check out ramp right now
go to ramp.com are you looking for a
better way to simplify your business
finances across expenses vendor payments
and accounting if so ramp could be a
complete game changer for your business
ramp is a corporate card and expense
management software designed to help you
save time and money with ram you can
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to the time he'll save each month on
employee expenses will allow you to
close your books eight times faster
businesses that use Ram
save an average of three and a half
percent within the first year ramp is
easy to use you get started in less than
15 minutes whether you have five
employees or five thousand right now
at 250 when you join ramp go to ramp.com
Knowles kwles cards issued by Sutton
Bank and Celtic Bank members FDIC terms
and conditions apply
speaking of transvestites
so I I got in trouble a few weeks ago
for pointing out or even just hosting a
woman for an interview who pointed out
that
pornography is turning a lot of people
trans
and Media Matters or my publicists over
there mocked me for this and criticized
me for this and a lot of liberals have
mocked and criticized this idea that
pornography addiction to pornography
increasingly weird pornography is
largely responsible for turning lots of
otherwise basically normal people trans
and
I you know I hate to say I told you so
the two guys who made The Matrix
the Wachowski brothers
they both went trans which is kind of
strange that two brothers around the
same time would go trans is a video now
circulating it's been dug up of one of
the Wachowski Brothers Andy Wachowski
explaining
that I'm totally right
to be honest like for me the the people
that I saw the first images that really
struck a chord with me were you know
trans women and pornography and um
there was something that
um unlocked and my brain
that I saw these uh wonderful Fearless
performers
um becoming these um becoming desirable
and
I in my head I could take the leap where
I felt like well me if I could be
desirable then maybe I could be loved
and for me that's like one of the keys
that trans people have to like struggle
through you know will somebody love me
and
so yeah that's that's my answer Nick
Adams it's an excellent answer Lily
Wachowski
so Andy now goes by Lily
what he described as his experience is
one of the most prominent trans
identifying people in America is exactly
what I said happened for which I was
criticized by all the libs
but of course that happens what did
Wachowski say
he said I was watching this kind of
weird porn so I was going down a rabbit
hole and then something got unlocked in
my brain
and I viewed myself differently
and I cultivated a new kind of Desire
a a new vision of how I desired even to
be desirable
to others
and then I viewed myself as a woman
yeah I think that happens for a lot of
people
the only ones talking about this are the
feminists and the actual conservatives
the squishes and the libs and the center
right and the center life and the people
in the middle they refuse to acknowledge
that
porn and depravity and vice
are largely responsible for the spread
of the transgender identity and ideology
but this is how desire is formed
desire is not just something that you're
born with and it remains exactly the
same over time it's not merely something
that pops up one day
and now you've got this desire for the
rest of your life desire is a complex
interplay of aspects of your nature and
aspects of your acculturation that
develop and deepen or they lessen over
time the scientific jargon for this
always involves neural pathways
and I don't mean to mock the scientific
jargon too much if that helps you to see
what the phenomenon is then that's great
but people will say well look if you if
you're a big fat guy and whenever you're
feeling a little down or anxious or
bored or so you go eat an ice cream pop
then you're going to deepen the neural
Pathways you're going to deepen the the
reward mechanism
and so whenever you start to feel that
way you're going to eat the ice cream
pop and it's going to make you fatter
but it's going to be harder to break
that but you could you could make the
same kind of observation about a heroin
addict you can make the same observation
about a pornography addict you could
make the same observation about anybody
engaging in any kind of
a habitual behavior that is how desires
form the reason the science jargon is
not all that persuasive is because we're
not just bodies we're not just bags of
chemicals and brains inside a skeleton
but we're body and soul and so the way
that I think is simpler and more precise
to talk about it is is that this is how
our desires
are formed and that's exactly the kind
of language that Wachowski is using
so on the one side of transgender
observations you've got Michael Knowles
and one of the most prominent
transvestites in America
and the people who say we're wrong are a
bunch of Libs over at Media Matters can
you imagine can you imagine but that's
obviously
I think we're on the right side of that
speaking of Desire
got a great story a very rare great
story in the news that has nothing to do
with weird sex stuff it has nothing to
do with immigration has nothing to do
with the Democrats destroying our
culture this is just a great story
there's a 45 year old high school
custodian and part-time Barber
who just earned his high school diploma
this is a guy I saw this story pop up
local news story
45 year old Elmo de Silva this was
reported by Atlanta news first
he's custodian for the Indian Creek
Elementary School in Clarkston
and he just joined over 40 other adults
who got their High School diplomas
during a recent ceremony he said
it wasn't easy it was a struggle for a
while and to achieve and get through it
and looking back I'm very proud
this guy had to drop out of high school
to take care of his younger brothers
now all these years later he's gone back
gotten his high school diploma I think
it's great big congratulations to that
guy and the political lesson to take and
the personal lesson for all of us is
it's a reminder
that it is never too late to improve
yourself
we are often tempted to think oh it's
too late I can't fix my situation
my family situation
my professional situation my male
education
my vice my bad habits my addictions my
it's just too light it's too far gone
you know old dog ain't gonna change its
spots
and and people are tempted to think this
way from the time they're five years old
but we're always tempted to think this
way but it's just not true it's never
too late Jeremy
the god king Jeremy boring just made
this point on Twitter today on a fairly
unrelated topic he said that it's never
too late until it is until you're going
into the ground it's not too late so you
you can improve yourself and a lot of
people think
that in our culture which is so depraved
it's got just such
Madness and addiction all around we're
in the throes of the worst opioid crisis
ever we've got the average life
expectancy decreasing these of deaths of
Despair obviously all the weird sex
stuff going on uh family breakdown
loneliness epidemic it's very easy to
think oh well it's just it's all too far
gone there's no way we can ever yes you
can you can over the way you overcome it
one is to turn to God and accept God's
grace and then to cooperate with that
Grace and just take it one day at a time
and you just go back to that classroom
for one day and then you go back the
next day and you go back the next day
and you keep doing your job and guess
what
after a while you've got a high school
diploma after a while you've
cured that addiction after or greatly
abated the addiction after a while
you've grown in virtue after a while
it's not too late
you're a human being with reason and
will you can do a lot speaking of
Education chip Roy
Republican congressman from Texas all
around National Treasure chip Roy just
gave a great education to the chief
legal and strategy officer for the
National Abortion Federation
in 2015 the Center for Medical progress
released a video on which you stated
quote I'm like oh my God I get it when
the skull is broken that's really sharp
I get it I understand why people are
talking about getting that skull out
that covarium
covarian being an incomplete skull
when abortion is crushed the skulls of
babies to kill them
what physical risks are there for the
baby
so Congressman thank you for the
question it allows me to clarify that
the media products you're referring to
stoked a massive uptick in violence
those heavily edited misleadingly edited
media products caused three murders and
nine woundings in Colorado Springs in
20. the question was about the baby and
the skull crushing that is I think a
direct quote attributed to you
well uh uh Congressman I look this is
the deceptively edited you don't know
what the and he says well you said this
we have your words about crushing baby
skulls
we got we got video it's from the Center
for Medical progress and she's just
trying to back out of it she's trying to
deny her own words she's trying to deny
the reality but chip Roy won't let it go
folks who distributed those media
products may have attributed something
to me I can't speak to it so true or
false did you say that I'm like oh my
God I get it when the skull is broken
that's really sharp did you say that
it's impossible to know Congressman
would you have said that it says that
something you would have said I don't
know you don't know you don't know if
you talked about the crushing of the
skull of a baby
you don't remember having said something
like that I'm pretty confident I've
never said something like that
I'm quite confident my colleagues here
have never said something like that
have you ever said something about
crushing the skull of the baby
particularly in that kind of a setup I
believe Congressman that we all came
here today to agree that violence is
never an appropriate response to policy
difference that that seems pretty
violent the crushing of the skull of a
baby I love this it goes on we don't
have time to play the whole thing he
won't let her change the subject what
does she do she pulls this lib card
at the moment he says hey we got you on
video talking about crushing the skulls
of little babies and how that's really
what abortion is you said that huh she
goes people who if you oppose the
slaughter of babies that you're
encouraging violence
what are you talking about woman I'm
talking I'm I'm quoting your words back
to you that we have on video
ending violence against the sacred
beautiful virtuous abortionists no I'm
not I'm not advocating whatever you're
talking about did you say what you
obviously said
well there's no way of knowing what do
you mean there's no way of knowing
you're calling the video a deep fake
here's there's no way of knowing oh
that's also not much of a denial as chip
Roy points out
because I'm pretty sure I've never
advocated crushing the skulls of babies
have you
I don't think I've said it those words
you you're not sure if you said those
words
and he won't let her change the subject
very often what Dems want to do is
they'll if you say hey we probably
shouldn't Slaughter like 800 000 little
innocent babies a year right they'll say
well do you support increased welfare
payments like yeah I don't know maybe
yeah what do you let's talk about that
after that has nothing to do with what
we shouldn't murder babies right well do
you support Planned Parenthood education
in elementary schools no I don't stop
changing the subject lady don't kill the
babies end of discussion
that's it okay that's it that's enough
and Chip Roy he will not be distracted
because well you're encouraging violence
yeah I'm pretty sure murdering babies is
violent take a lesson chip Roy National
Treasure
sounds good he looks good doing it when
you want to look good you got to check
out genucel right now go to genucel.com
Knowles did you know our friends at
geniusell have upgraded their most
popular package to feature their top
selling deep firming vitamin C serum
plus Ultra retinol moisturizer with
natural retinol alternative did you know
that
right now you can take advantage of this
limited time package upgrade for seventy
seven zero percent off why waste time
and money to go get work done to your
face when you can get geniusell skin
care shipped right to your door here's a
geniusell.com review from Robert in
blessing Texas quote I purchased genucel
as a gift for my girlfriend she said she
saw the results so fast her skin is
noticeably softer and smoother I can see
and feel a difference too she was
already beautiful and geniusell has made
her more beautiful geniuselle's secret
is a family recipe for over 20 years
that makes it safe for all skin types
and perfect for both men and women you
might think that it's only women buying
this turns out actually probably
slightly more men than women I also love
the founder a compounding pharmacist he
makes it in small batches he's a
Christian from Egypt who left Egypt for
the American dream it's just a great guy
great company great product go to
geniusell.com's most popular package for
seventy seven zero percent off featuring
both jsl's Ultra retinol and Geniuses
Firming Serum get a complimentary spot
essential specs with every package order
plus free upgrade to priorityshipping
geniusell.com Knowles
you might have been one of the tens of
millions of people who watched Netflix's
hit show making a murderer if so then
you are going to love daily wire Plus's
new exclusive 10-part docu-series with
Candace Owens convicting a murderer
coming this summer
whether it's exposing black lives matter
or the fallacies in the healthcare
industry regarding covid
and this is never afraid to challenge
the official narrative she will find the
truth wherever it leads when Candace
found out
the key facts may have been omitted in
Netflix's series she set out to uncover
the real story behind the notorious
Steven Avery case
the end result is convicting a murderer
you will not want to miss it right now
there's never been a better time to
become a daily wire plus member sign up
now for convicting a murderer you will
receive an early bird discount of 30 off
your daily wire Plus Membership when you
use the code truth this is your last
chance for 30 off so do not wait until
the series comes out this summer
you'll also get all of the other premium
content from DIY plus including the
greatest lie ever sold what is a woman
and the largest collection of content
from Dr Jordan B Peterson join now at
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member and see the truth when it finally
comes out
speaking of conservatives standing out
it's not just chip Roy Tommy tuberville
also Senator tuberville is holding up a
defense spending measure and he's doing
it specifically over abortion policy
squares are paying
for paying for uh three extra weeks off
I mean it it's just it's atrocious
what's going on here but they
politicized it uh and I'm on I'm
standing from by my work uh I've sent
them uh the memo uh that that uh
secretary Austin you know put out said
we're going to do it this way and uh and
of course I went right back at him so if
you do you're not going to do any
promotions as long as you do it that way
so uh they think they're going to get me
to change it that's not going to happen
uh so uh we're just going to keep on
with this and hopefully they'll come to
realization that uh we've got a few
people over here to fight yeah most of
them are we've got a few that I've
disappointed in uh you know as I stood
up in a Caucus meeting the other day I
said either we're pro-life or we're not
okay uh you know and to me that's one of
the top uh policies that we have in the
Republican party is that we're pro-life
and I understand there's some exceptions
and we've always used exceptions in the
military of rape incest and healthy mom
um and we've never had a problem in the
military but they're trying to
politicize the military so much
radicalize it it's just everything that
they're doing everything they touch you
know turns to socialism and so uh if we
don't stand up in the Republican party
it doesn't get some backbone uh you know
this country's gone as we know it okay
so what is Senator trevorville talking
about
military policy that would give benefits
to people who want to kill their kids
and say okay you got some time off you
get this kind of subsidy so we're gonna
that's gonna be the military policy we
don't need to pass this through the
legislature because it's just going to
be set by the bureaucrats over at the
Pentagon and that's that
and Senator tuberville he frames it in a
way that's quite clever he's saying
listen we we accept the exceptions
that are long-standing practice
by the Pentagon now do pro-lifers really
accept the exception that in some cases
a baby's life matters but in other cases
it doesn't or something like that from a
principled standpoint uh probably not
from a practical standpoint okay if you
can reduce 99 of abortion
not a bad place to begin but
he says this new policy no
we're not going to allow the defense
department to start
subsidizing abortions with our taxpayer
money that's not going to happen and so
I'm going to hold up this defense
spending Bill until they fix it
and you're going to hear the squishes
say we can't hold up the defense
spending Bill we've got to give all that
money to Ukraine or something we we're
about to be on the brink of World War
III because of Biden's stupid foreign
policy or something like that but
terrible says yeah well I'm going to
hold it up so I guess you better change
the policy if you're so afraid that
we're about to descend into World War
III then I should hope that you're not
willing to throw the whole country away
turn us into a slave to China or
something like that because you want to
give some extra time off to to people so
they can go kill their children yeah I'm
not backing down so I hope you do but
I'm going to call your bluff let's play
chicken and I I think this is exactly
the right strategy why not why not
the the people have very little control
over the government at all anymore
no matter what the holdups are in the
legislature and the executive the
government always seems to get funded
there seems to be no shortage of money
for the federal government no shortage
of power for them and so terrible saying
yeah you're not getting Maya sent to
this now fix it or we're done we're
pro-life or we're not absolutely the
right strategy
speaking of mass murder
there's a somewhat breaking news story I
haven't seen updates about it this
morning
I just saw it come across last night
a U-Haul
driven apparently by Nazis
crashed into a pole in Washington DC
and nobody seems to have been hurt
nobody really can tell what the
point of this attack was no one can
really tell
what it was attacking but one thing we
do know is the U-Haul gently crashed
into some poles
and then a bunch of media came out and
the people in the press and the First
Responders come out and they open up the
back of the U-Haul and there's not a lot
in the back of the U-Haul but they find
a big Nazi flag like a big swastika a
red flag and these First Responders this
is really
really meticulous how they did this they
laid out that big Nazi flag looks brand
new crisp and shiny and they lay it out
right on the pavement just perfectly set
up for the cameras to take those photos
and then
the cameras get their photos and they
kind of put it away and that's all we
know about it
I can't help but notice that
that kind of weird
it's just weird I didn't think there
were a lot of Nazis in America
I don't I don't see Nazis I don't I
don't run into them on the street
I know that's kind of interesting and I
don't see what the point of this attack
would be I don't even really see how
it's an attack and you'd think if these
were old-timey Nazis they'd probably
have a nice battered tattered weathered
flag not like a brand new one looks like
it was just purchased it's just kind of
strange
just kind of strange I was laid out just
perfectly for the cameras and so I don't
know I just think that's all a little
bit weird
call me crazy that's all I have to say
on the alleged Nazi attack who knew
good old America just teeming with Nazis
we never find out very much about all
those Nazis they always seem to sort of
disappear but we read a lot of headlines
about them liberal establishment loves
talking about all of these elusive Nazis
really strange now speaking of our crazy
political environment
we have a new candidate for president
that man's name
Tim Scott
I'm announcing today
that I'm running
for a president
of the United States
of America
you see they're attacking our American
values our schools
our economy and our security
but not on my watch not on my watch
that won't work America
is not a nation
okay so you see here the the audio cuts
out that's not a problem with the
podcast and and Tim responds that yes
America is not a nation in all right it
goes on for a while and we'll skip ahead
okay Mike's back on good yes
but under Joe Biden our nation is not a
nation in Decline but under Joe Biden we
have become a nation in retreat
the timing
all nature is but art unknown to the ill
chance Direction which thou can't not
see Tim Scott very very nice guy I
really personally like Tim Scott a lot
I I we expected that he would probably
run for president that was teased I
think about a year ago by his publisher
and so he'll he'll now join The Fray
Tim Scott
to his credit is launching a different
kind of campaign than his competitors in
the Republican field
Tim Scott is launching a campaign
premised on America is not in Decline
every other candidate Trump DeSantis
Vivek Nikki are there other candidate
maybe ASA Hutchinson there's some other
candidates in the race Joe exotic
they're running campaigns based on how
America is in steep decline we've got to
turn that around
Tim Scott says we are not in Decline
but the Providence The Coincidence of
we are not a nation and oh we our
microphones don't even work
is our electrical grid strong is our can
we communicate anymore and so it cuts
out for a while it comes back on he says
okay where was I oh yeah America's not a
nation in Decline it's a hard argument
to make
it could be an appealing campaign thesis
in the same way that Ronald Reagan was
so appealing morning in America make
America feel good about herself again
well I believe America's Best Days lie
ahead of us
you think well
listen Gipper I'm all for Hope Hope
Springs Eternal in the human breast and
you know you've done a great job
restoring America but are you sure about
that I don't know we've got like
sacrilegious drag queens jigging or
jiggling around Dodger Stadium are you
sure America's best days are ahead you
sure that's better than say I don't know
the white picket fences of the 1950s you
sure that's better than 1776 I don't
know I don't know
a little bit skeptical
but that's what that's what Senator
Scott is running on
he's saying we are not in Decline it's
just that Joe Biden's a jerk
could be an appealing campaign and and
he's also giving himself his own lane
now
so he's going to be the nice guy he is
genuinely one of the nicest guys in
politics it's going to be upbeat it's
going to be optimistic
maybe that plays maybe that place who
knows I mean everyone
laughs because everyone believes that
the race is totally set in stone there's
no changing the outcome of the race it's
either going to be Trump or maybe it'll
be DeSantis
presidential campaigns are crazy and
unpredictable the only thing that you
can reasonably expect is the unexpected
now how does the race stand as of right
now
despite what you may have heard in the
news despite the constant negative press
confer Trump is leading by a lot by a
lot according to morning consult these
numbers are about a week old at this
point
Trump is up
43 points over DeSantis
it's not that Trump's at 43. Trump is at
61. he's 43 points above DeSantis who's
at 18. Pence at six Haley at four of the
bank at four Liz Cheney for some reason
is there still uh Greg Abbott Tim
Scott's at one percent
ASA Hutchinson so Trump is way up
and the race is moving more and more in
Trump's
Direction
okay how is DeSantis doing
yeah Trump is up on DeSantis in Georgia
buy a fair bit Trump is up even in
Georgia by 7.8 percent
uh desantis's favorability is down
desantis's favorability it's still
pretty strong it's just down Trump's the
most favorable GOP candidate at 78 uh 28
view Trump unfavorably uh
to say Trump had been at 79 but he's
still basically around there DeSantis
has the second highest favorability he's
at 66 percent
but that's a decrease so the numbers
moving in the wrong direction that's
down from 72 percent who viewed him
favorably the week before it's down from
73 of people who viewed him favorably
the week before that
so it's moving in
the wrong direction for him what does
the Santa say
desantis's response is that
he Ron DeSantis is the only Republican
who can win he said you have basically
three people at this point that are
credible in this whole thing Biden Trump
and me
and I think of those three two have a
chance to get elected President Biden
and Me based on all the data in the
swing States now this is a good response
to all of these polls which nationally
are not looking great for Ron DeSantis
because what DeSantis is saying is hey
the primary isn't a national contest the
primary is a state-by-state contest and
so
yeah maybe Trump is way up on me
nationally but that's not going to
decide the nomination and that's not
going to decide the general election
what's going to decide both of those
things are a handful of states and in
those handful of states that tend to be
a little bit more moderate and maybe
they don't like Trump as much now Trump
is going to say actually they do like me
much more than they like other
Republicans because I brought out voters
who previously would not be Republican
and probably wouldn't even vote but
DeSantis is going to say no those
Suburban moms those people in the middle
they're going to pick me over Trump so
don't focus on the national numbers
focus on Ohio focus on
North Carolina Focus on Florida focus on
Arizona focus on Wisconsin focus on
Michigan
that's going to be where the election is
decided who's going to win I don't know
what are you asking me for my favorite
comment yesterday is from JJ hervey who
says
we're not grooming kids says the company
named Target maybe Target will change
its name from Target to tuck it
tuck it that's
that's pretty good
I came across a video
of a therapist this is a 15-year veteran
therapist she's been in the job for a
long time she's very clearly a lib
and she
gave one of the most precise and
insightful
definitions of wokeness a word that has
eluded definition in certain quarters
that I have ever heard
it's only really over the past six or
seven months that I've understood
um my racial identity and begun to
really deconstruct it personally and
from within and understanding that in
terms of the psychology of white folks
who are my people I grew up in Seattle
very like liberal whiteness environment
and that is I'm in that environment
still so
um yeah and I work as a therapist I've
been working as a therapist for about 15
years
so I really see this as a um a healing
journey and to me
really the
only real spiritual path of meaning
available to my folks so and I yeah
there it is
wokeness she says is the only real
spiritual path of meaning available to
white folks that is how they View
wokeness by which they mean
a particularly virulent form of leftist
politics
and that is true
it's not literally true but that that
perception is
is accurate to them that's that's how
they are perceiving this thing
this is why the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence have to be allowed to mock
Christianity at Dodger Stadium
because the libs have foreclosed the
possibility that
Christianity is a path of spiritual
meaning that God is a path of spiritual
meaning that a relationship with our
maker and our savior
will give us spiritual meaning that is
foreclosed to them
or the concept of original sin they have
rejected that they don't believe that
they do recognize that sin and death
pervade the world which are the
consequences of original sin so how do
they make sense of that
the way that they try to make sense of
that is by saying that this is not a
consequence of original sin but it's a
consequence of institutional sin that
over the years
man-made traditions and institutions
have built up and they have oppressed
people and they've kept people down now
a logical question for this in response
would be okay well how did those
institutions and practices and
traditions get corrupted in the first
place they don't answer that part but
there are many people who believe that
there are many people who even say that
they're on the right there are some
people who even say that they're
Christian who are very
anti-institutional very anti-tradition
very anti-ritual
they they partake to some degree of the
same
skepticism of and frankly disdain for
tradition
Institution
history
the the weight of practice the the
Democracy of the Dead that has been
built up our whole culture our whole
civilization and so for the libs in
despair they say okay I don't God isn't
real
Christianity isn't true I probably don't
even have a soul nothing seems to have
meaning at all and so the only way that
I can
I can impose some sort of meaning on my
life is through what is most
uh perceptible to me which is my flesh
my skin color there that by by
orienting my entire moral view around
just flesh and just literally the color
of my meat of My Flesh
that will give me some kind of spiritual
meaning
obviously it is not going to work
but that's how they view it
that's why they've got to allow the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence to
jiggle around the stadium
they believe that the sis the real
sisters the real religious sisters the
carmelites the the the nuns
that they are the threat because what
they represent is a restriction on
individual autonomy which is evil which
is it comes from the devil that's that
that's the sin the institutional sin
we've got to fight back against
and so this the sac religious character
of the sister of Perpetual indulgences
performance that's that's not a bug of
their troop that's a feature that's the
whole point that's why they have to be
exalted at Dodger Stadium
because the alternative would be okay we
we boot out these weird jiggling
and we we allow the religious
nuns to come in and I don't know say a
prayer or benediction before the the
baseball game
but then to do that
would be to say okay well
Christianity is true traditional
religion is true and this woke false
religion that's false and we're going to
suppress that from the Public Square
because that way lies Madness that way
Lies True oppression spiritual
oppression that way lies Decay and
decadence and degradation you've got to
pick one you can't you can't
simultaneously have them
both okay there's a very important point
that I've got to get to
which is from The New York Times
magazine from the ethicist
my husband flies first class and puts me
in coach is that fair this question
written into the ethicist is just the
kind of like
gossipy advice columns sort of Saucy
little advice column for the New York
Times magazine they try to dress up and
make it seem more erudite so the
question is my husband flies first class
and puts me in coach is that fair
everyone's talking about it so I guess
I'll weigh into especially someone who
likes to take my free upgrades on my
airplanes but sweet little Elisa doesn't
always want to do that because then she
would maybe have to leave the kids in
the back and she doesn't want to leave
the kids in the back
I would throw the kids in steerage you
know listen it's tough out there it
builds character daddy will give you a
hug once we land wherever we're going so
she says my husband loves to travel and
always either pays for gets an upgrade
to First Class
we travel with our children he buys
himself a ticket in first puts us in
economy or economy Plus
even did this to Paris
and he justifies flying alone in first
because of the cost and the fact that
our kids might feel alone if I were to
travel in first and leave
and with him and leave them in the rear
cabin I feel that this is unfair okay
oh and she says I don't think our kids
would mind if they were an economy plus
and my husband and I sat together but he
says no can't do that so the husband is
is wrong here it's unshillable wrist not
nice you you should offer your wife the
upgrade even if you're only getting one
upgrade as this happens sometimes and
you should slum it and Coach if you have
to
but
if given the option here you're talking
12 and 16.
these are these are kids who are pretty
big all right I got my first job I was
working at 14. walking uphill in the
snow both directions okay
uh 12 years old that you're old enough
to sit alone 16 as certainly you are
it's okay the parents can sit in first
class
the kids can sit back in economy or even
economy plus it's pretty nice I didn't
fly economy plus until I was in my 20s
but the husband should be
chivalrous
wives submit to their husbands and
husbands are called to love their wives
as Christ loves his church
and I think that probably involves
giving up your first class upgrade
today is what is today Tuesday
today is
I don't have a good I don't have a good
alliterative title for this it's James
Bond Tuesday I don't know
Ben Davies tells me that there are new
odds out there for who the next James
Bond is going to be
we're going to be playing the odds game
here I want to get your thoughts on who
that is
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code Knowles Canada wlas a checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]